hi schön dass ihr wieder dabei seid bei
ZDF heute live vielleicht habt ihr in
den letzten Wochen schon vom sogenannten
verbrennerstreit gehört da geht es zum
einen um die EU auf der einen Seite und
auf der anderen Seite steht unser FTP
Verkehrsminister Volker Wissing der
Grund ist für diesen Streit in der EU
hat man sich eigentlich auf einen aus
für neue Autos mit Verbrennungsmotoren
ab 2035 geeinigt und Deutschland besser
gesagt der FDP Verkehrsminister Volker
Wissing bremst das jetzt auf den letzten
Metern er will nämlich dass Autos mit
Verbrenner Antrieb auch 2035 noch
zugelassen werden können wenn sie
synthetische Kraftstoffe tanken die
nennt man efuels habt ihr vielleicht
schon gehört dem Begriff aktuell tagte
im Brüssel ein EU-Gipfel und der Druck
auf Wissing ist aktuell ziemlich groß
und jetzt gleich steht deshalb ein
Präsident von Volker Wissing aus der
Mainzer fdparteizentrale an und da sind
wir für euch natürlich mit ZDF heute
live dabei da sehen wir schon aktuell
steht da noch niemand ganz interessant
vielleicht dazu das hat Volker Wissing
heute morgen noch getwittert ich zeige
euch das mal hier auf meinem PC wir
wollen das Auto ist die mit
klimafreundlichen Kraftstoffen betrieben
werden auch in Zukunft neu zugelassen
werden können unser Vorschlag an die
EU-Kommission ist das Aus für das
Verbrenner aus ja wissingsposition
scheint also ziemlich klar zu sein so
richtig viel bewegt sich in dem Streit
aktuell nicht über dieses Statement
gleich von Wessing und auch generell
über den Streit zwischen ihm und der EU
darüber möchten wir hier heute bei ZDF
heute live sprechen zum mal mit meiner
Kollegin Christiane hübscher in Berlin
und meiner Kollegin Isabel Schäfers in
Brüssel und natürlich wie immer auch mit
euch wenn ihr Fragen zum Thema habt an
meine beiden Kollegen dann schickt sie
gerne direkt hier im Youtube Chat oder
per Mail an ZDF heute - live at zdf.de
ich würde sagen jetzt gucken wir aber
erstmal nach Berlin zu meiner Kollegin
Christiane
ja hallo aus Berlin hi Christiane schön
dass du bei uns bist ja zu diesem Streit
hat er heute morgen irgendwie eine
ziemliche Verwirrung geherrscht da gab
es verschiedene Medienberichte kannst du
uns erzählen was da genau der Stand ist
ja also du hast völlig recht das Chaos
ist perfekt kann man sagen ähm nicht nur
in Brüssel sondern auch in Berlin
niemand weiß mehr so richtig was Volker
Wissing eigentlich will es begann heute
morgen damit dass der Spiegel getitelt
hat ich zitiere mal Verkehrsministerium
lenkt im Verbrenner Streit offenbar ein
da dachte man okay die Kuh ist womöglich
vom Eis kurze Zeit später schreibt die
neue Osnabrücker Zeitung Wissing bleibt
im Verbrenner Streit hart und dann
dachte man natürlich so was sind da
jetzt los ja ähm dann haben wir also mal
im Verkehrsministerium angerufen und
haben gefragt wie wie ist denn jetzt die
Lage ist der Streit jetzt gelöst und
dann hieß es von daher nein äh es gibt
eigentlich noch gar keinen Kompromiss
was der Spiegel schreibe würde würde so
nicht stimmen er das was die neue
osnabrück Zeitung schreibt und es hieß
also man sei von einem Kompromiss immer
noch entfernt es gebe einen munteren
Briefwechsel zwischen Brüssel und Berlin
hin und her und ja ob das jetzt positiv
oder negativ ausgehen würde könnte man
nicht sagen alles schreiben würden
aktuell geprüft im
Bundesverkehrsministerium um die
Verwirrung perfekt zu machen hat heute
Vormittag der Bundeswirtschaftsminister
Robert Habeck in Kopenhagen wo er gerade
auf Dienstreise ist gesagt ähm ich
glaube dass wir eine Einigung haben mein
Verständnis ist dass es bereits eine
Einigung gibt und er hoffe dass seine
Interpretation richtig ist daran sieht
man schon mal wie wie verrückt das auch
innerhalb der Bundesregierung gerade
kommuniziert wird nämlich offensichtlich
gar nicht bis ja also wahrscheinlich gar
nicht auch aus dem Umweltministerium da
haben wir nachgefragt da sagt man uns
weiß wir wissen nicht wir wissen nicht
wie die Lage ist wir wissen nicht ob
Volker Wissing jetzt dieses Verbrenner
aus mitträgt oder wie das am Ende
ausgehen wird also es ist gerade
verrückt das klingt ziemlich verwirrend
auch interessant dass auch innerhalb der
Ampel da nicht ganz klar zu sein scheint
wie Völker Wissing da gerade ist ich
gucke mal parallel noch ein bisschen auf
die Bilder aber Volk noch nicht vor der
gelben Wand Christiane lass uns
vielleicht mal um ein bisschen Klarheit
in die Thematik zu bekommen auf einen
Stück von dir gucken was so ein bisschen
erklärt was die EU-Kommission gerade
vorschlägt
die EU-Kommission bietet dem deutschen
Verkehrsminister an für synthetische
Kraftstoffe sogenannte e-fiols ab 2035
eine extra autokategorie einzuführen in
dem Papier heißt es solche CO2-neutralen
Verbrenner müssen so gebaut sein dass
sie mit keinem anderen Kraftstoff fahren
können wenn reguläres Benzin oder Diesel
eingefüllt wird muss das Auto dies
erkennen und darf nicht starten aber
kann man Autos tatsächlich so klug
machen dass sie merken ob sie
klimafreundlich betankt werden
Autoexperten sagen ja es braucht gewisse
Sensorik und eine Software die dann
erkennt dass tatsächlich efuels ja
getankt werden noch einfacher ist
einfach ein entsprechenden
Einfüllstutzen zu bauen der ist aber
dann nicht so Missbrauch sicher wie eine
Software
das ist also der Vorschlag der EU
-Kommission so ein Stück weit zu gehen
oder ist das denn überhaupt überhaupt
technisch möglich solche ja das quasi
ein Auto erkennt was da gerade in den
Tank läuft ja wir haben ja gerade gehört
was Herr Bratzel Stefan Brassel der
automobilexperte dazu gesagt hat also es
ginge theoretisch das ist im Grunde
genommen nur eine Frage des Geldes also
man kann Autos Neuwagen so bauen dass
man eben eine bestimmte Sensorik da
einbaut eine Software im Grunde genommen
die dann erkennt da wird Benzin oder
Diesel eingefüllt oder eben
klimafreundliche und wenn es nicht diese
ifür sind dann würde dieses Auto stoppen
oder man löst das ganze über so einen
Einfüllstutzen ja den wir kennen den
alle von der von der Tankstelle die man
da einstellt oh ich sehe gerade
nicht unterbrechen das einmal wir
schalten einmal rüber zu wissen und
hören uns das an danke dir
soweit sind
[Musik]
wir verhandeln seit Wochen mit der
EU-Kommission über die Frage wie
schaffen wir es eine flotten
grenzwertregulierung Technologie neutral
zu gestalten das ist für die Freien
Demokraten ein wichtiges Anliegen dass
wir bereits im Koalitionsvertrag fest
verankert haben wir hatten erwartet dass
die EU-Kommission dazu einen konkreten
Vorschlag vorliegt der liegt noch nicht
vor wir arbeiten jetzt in engen
Gesprächen mit der EU-Kommission an
einem solchen Konzept ich habe gestern
der EU-Kommission konkrete
Umsetzungsvorschläge gemacht um dafür zu
sorgen dass Verbrennungsmotoren auch
nach 2035 weiter zugelassen und genutzt
werden können wenn sie ausschließlich
mit synthetischen Kraftstoffen betankt
werden
das ist ein Weg der jetzt von der
EU-Kommission beantwortet worden ist mit
einem Schreiben das mich optimistisch
stimmt jetzt müssen letzte juristische
Fragen noch geklärt werden was die
technische Umsetzung dieses Vorschlags
angeht warum war uns das so wichtig wir
wollen sicherstellen dass wir bei der
Umstellung auf klimaneutrale Mobilität
nicht nur auf eine Technologie setzen
die Elektromobilität die ist verfügbar
und sie bietet viele gute Möglichkeiten
mobil zu sein daneben haben wir aber
auch die Perspektive mit dem
Verbrennungsmotor wenn er mit
synthetischen Kraftstoffen betankt wird
ein Mobilitätsangebot zu machen den
Verbrennungsmotor beherrschen wir in
Europa besser als andere in der Welt
insbesondere hier in Deutschland sind
wir führend in dieser Technologie diese
Technologie jetzt zu verbieten macht
keinen Sinn denn mehrere Angebote
schaffen immer mehr Wettbewerb und auch
bessere Preise für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und darauf kommt es mir an
ich muss sicherstellen dass nicht nur im
nächsten Jahrzehnt sondern auch darüber
hinaus für alle Bürgerinnen und Bürger
die auf ein Auto angewiesen sind ein
bezahlbares individuelles
Mobilitätsangebot zur Verfügung steht
und
bezahlbare Preise die entstehen in der
Regel nicht indem man Technologien
ausschließt und sich nur noch auf einen
Weg beschränkt sondern bezahlbare Preise
die sichert man durch Wettbewerb
Wettbewerb der Anbieter aber auch
Wettbewerb der Technologien und dieser
Wettbewerb kann auch dazu führen dass
wir beim Klimaschutz schneller
vorankommen auch das ist uns ein
wichtiges Anliegen wir stellen die Ziele
ab 2035 nur noch klimaneutrale Fahrzeuge
zuzulassen nicht in Frage das haben wir
auch nie getan uns geht es nur darum
dass der Verbrennungsmotor als
technologische Option geschützt bleibt
zugelassen bleibt und wir unsere Stärken
auch in Zukunft voll ausspielen können
das hat auch wichtige Signale für
unseren Industriestandort und insofern
hoffe ich
aber auch mit großer Zuversicht dass wir
mit der EU-Kommission hier diesen
gemeinsamen Weg beschreiten können davon
wird ganz Europa profitieren und wir
haben große Unterstützung auch von
anderen Mitgliedstaaten und ich bin sehr
dankbar dass wir im engen Austausch auch
gemeinsam mit uns jetzt auf den Weg
machen und
Technologieneutralität in der
europäischen Regulierung verankern
um die Streik Auswirkung auf die
Logistik am Montag aufzufangen meine
Frage ist wie steht das
Verkehrsministerium dazu und was ist
möglicherweise dazu schon geplant oder
in Aussicht wir unterstützen das und
haben die in Länder auch geraten dass
man keine Kontrollen durchführen sollte
am Sonntag wenn man es jetzt nicht
schnell schafft das umzusetzen wir
müssen alle Maßnahmen ergreifen um dafür
zu sorgen dass die Logistik funktioniert
und die Tarif Parteien habe ich
aufgefordert alles zu tun um die
Belastungen für die Bevölkerung so
gering wie möglich zu halten
in die Verhandlungen und auch in die
Entscheidung der einzelnen
tarifpartnerische ich mich als
Verkehrsminister nicht ein das ist deren
Aufgabe diese Dinge zu klären mal
Aufgabe ist es dafür zu sorgen dass
Mobilität und Logistik stabil bleiben
und die Möglichkeiten die wir hier haben
Bund und Länder gemeinsam die sollten
wir ausschöpfen
in der Nachfrage zum verbrennerstreit
ein Thema ist ja die Rechtssicherheit
wie können die bei
einem Kompromiss ihrer Meinung nach
sichergestellt werden
nun wir haben dafür konkrete Vorschläge
gemacht wie wir mit entsprechenden
Rechtsetzung durch die EU-Kommission
sicherstellen können dass zunächst
einmal die Kategorie der
verbrennungsfahrzeuge mit der Fahrzeuge
mit Verbrennungsmotor und synthetischen
Kraftstoffen geschaffen werden kann denn
wir brauchen ja eine spezielle
Fahrzeugkategorie Fahrzeuge die ein
Verbrennungsmotor haben aber
ausschließlich mit synthetischen
Kraftstoffen fahren da muss man
bestimmte Zulassungsvorschriften machen
etwa um sicherzustellen dass durch
Sensortechnik nicht auch andere
Kraftstoffe genutzt werden können dann
brauchen wir auch die Integration dieser
Fahrzeugkategorie in das bisherige und
künftige Regime und da müssen wir ganz
konkrete Schritte haben auch mit mit
Zeitplänen damit wir wissen dass das
auch kommt das ist mit der EU-Kommission
jetzt vorbereitet aber es sind noch
Fragen zu klären wir sind noch nicht
vollständig einig aber aber wichtig ist
dass wir gemeinsam an dem Ziel arbeiten
und am Ende auch sichergestellt wird
dass wir Technologieneutralität in
Europa verankern
nun wir haben jetzt die Verantwortung
dass diese Regulierung die wir auf den
Weg bringen eine gute ist bisher fehlt
das Element der technologieoffenheit
oder Technologie Neutralität das muss
noch hinein die flotten
grenzwertregulierung wie sie im Trilog
verabschiedet worden ist ist ein
Kompromiss den wir mittragen können aber
er hat eben dieses Manko der
Technologie Neutralität das wollen wir
ergänzen sicherstellen und wenn wir
wissen und auch verlässlich uns darauf
verständigen dass die EU-Kommission
diesen Weg geht und den ganz konkreten
auch umsetzt dann hat sich das für einen
wirklichen Mehrwert für Europa und bin
bin dann auch zufrieden
zum Streik Fernsehen
nun alle die sich auf diesen
Arbeitskampf entschieden für diesen
Arbeitskampf entschieden haben müssen
wissen dass das natürlich folgen hat
aber das ist nicht Aufgabe der
Bundesregierung dieser Abwägung zu
treffen sondern das Streikrecht steht
dem den Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmern zu und in welchem Umfang
wann es ausgeübt wird ist in deren
Verantwortung letztlich muss man aber
daran erinnern dass es natürlich wichtig
ist dass die Belastungen für die
Bevölkerung die ja an den
Tarifverhandlungen nicht beteiligt sind
dass die eben mit bedacht werden und wo
immer es möglich ist abgemildert werden
Menschen sollen nicht unter dem
Arbeitskampf oder den Tarifverhandlungen
leiden ich bin deswegen auch auf die hat
mich auch öffentlich geäußert und gesagt
man sollte in diesem Sinne ablegen
es ist klar dass das massive
Auswirkungen auf den Verkehr haben wird
und natürlich auch auf die Logistik
deswegen habe ich auch empfohlen dass
man keine Kontrollen des
sonntagfahrverbots macht um
entsprechende Vorkehrungen treffen zu
können
die Herstellung sehr energieintensiv das
heißt
wir wissen nicht wie sich die Dinge
entwickeln wir wissen auch nicht wie in
10 Jahren die Situation aussehen wird
wir brauchen weltweit klimaneutrale
Mobilität und viele stellen sich die
Frage stehen die Rohstoffe überhaupt
weltweit zur Verfügung um jedes Auto mit
einem fossilen Verbrennungsmotor durch
ein Batterie elektrischen Antrieb zu
ersetzen und weil man diese Fragen heute
nicht beantworten kann macht es keinen
Sinn Technologien zu verbieten das
Besondere ist ja wenn man eine
Technologie wie den Verbrennungsmotor
einmal in Europa aus der Hand gibt ist
der Wiedereinstieg in diese Technologie
fast ausgeschlossen denn die
Weiterentwicklung wird dann beendet und
die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass ich dann ein
Hersteller noch einmal auf einen solchen
Weg eines ist gering besser ist das man
behält die Technologie in Händen
entwickelt sie weiter mit Nutzung
synthetischer Kraftstoffe und wie die
Preise sich dieser Kraftstoffe in
Zukunft entwickeln was heute auch noch
niemand deswegen
entspricht der heutige Preis und die
heutige Verfügbarkeit von synthetischen
Kraftstoffen nicht dafür den
Verbrennungsmotor zu verbieten sondern
es ist ein gutes Argument zu sagen
technologieneutral weitermachen und
die Entwicklungen dann auch nutzen zu
können mehr Technologien bieten mehr
Chancen eine Technologie
und diese Frage geht es nicht denn
selbst wenn man diese Frage mit Nein
beantworten würde spreche das nicht für
das Verbot des Verbrennungsmotors mit
synthetischen Kraftstoffen denn etwas
das wenig genutzt werden wird oder
vielleicht gar nicht genutzt werden kann
muss man auch nicht verbieten aber weil
man nicht weiß wie diese Preise sich
entwickeln kann man getrost diese
technologieoffen halten und wir hören
von von
wirtschaftlichen Verantwortlichen die
sich intensiv synthetischen Kraftstoffen
beschäftigen dass Sie davon ausgehen
dass der Preis sich dahingehend
entwickeln wird dass das vergleichbar
ist mit Benzin oder Diesel und für
diesen Fall macht es Sinn dann die
Technologie zur Verfügung zu haben denn
am Ende brauchen wir für jede und jeden
ein bezahlbares Mobilitätsangebot wenn
man sich nur auf eine Technologie
verengt ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass
die Preise steigen größer als wenn man
mehrere Technologien nutzt nur darum
geht es uns um technologieoffenheit das
war immer der große Punkt und wenn wir
das jetzt noch in die Regulierung
hineinbringen dann glaube ich haben wir
auch mit diesen sicherlich anstrengenden
Diskussionen Europa einen großen Dienst
erwiesen aber auch und darauf kommt es
mir auch an für unser Land Mobilität für
jeden und jede in bezahlbarer Form
gesichert
haben
[Musik]
gesprochen
alle sind sehr stolz darauf die Menschen
die das Umsetzen streiten jetzt am
Montag die Strecken einmal wegen
Inflation und auch eigentlich um ihre
Job attraktiver zu machen also
ja über das 49 Euro Ticket sprechen wir
mal wann anders wir wollen jetzt erstmal
über dieses Statement zum
verbrennerstreit Sprechen mit meiner
Kollegin Christiane
Christiane was ziehst du jetzt aus
diesem Statement was sind die aktuellen
Ergebnisse hast du da vielleicht mehr
verstanden als ich tja das wage ich zu
bezweifeln ich würde mal sagen wir sind
nicht viel schlauer als vorher das geht
mir ganz genauso wie euch ähm mein Tipp
ist diese Einladung zu diesem
Pressestatement die kam zu früh also
offensichtlich hat man heute Morgen nach
der Antwort von der EU-Kommission in
Berlin im Verkehrsministerium gedacht
ach ja da haben wir jetzt eine Lösung
und hat also für 14 Uhr zu diesem
Statement eingeladen um dann fest zu
stellen nachdem man sich vielleicht
etwas tiefer über dieses Papier gebeugt
hat aber da haben wir doch noch
juristische und technische Nachfragen so
hat es Volker wissen ja gerade selber
bezeichnet und ähm da geht's jetzt
offensichtlich noch um die Details
sondern wollte man aber ganz
offensichtlich dieses Präsident jetzt
nicht wieder absagen und dann kommt eben
das raus was wir gerade gesehen haben
nämlich einen Minister der sagt ich bin
optimistisch dass wir eine Lösung
hinkriegen aber wir sind noch nicht da
das hat er ja ganz konkret gesagt
ja also was meint Volker Wissing wenn er
dann immer sagt es geht noch um
juristische Fragen es geht ihm um diese
sogenannte Rechtsverbindlichkeit also er
erwartet eben von der EU-Kommission
einen Gesetzentwurf einen Vorschlag der
sicherstellt im Sinne der FDP dass eben
Autos die ausschließlich mit e-fuse also
mit klimaneutralen Kraftstoffen fahren
können ab 2035 weiter zugelassen werden
können und wenn die EU-Kommission das
nicht so reinschreibt wie Herr Wissing
das gerne hätte dann so verstehe ich ihn
mag er nicht vor mager nicht zustimmen
das ist das ist im Grunde genommen die
gesamte Menge Lage wie das ausgeht keine
Ahnung offensichtlich gibt es weiter
eben
Briefwechsel zwischen Berlin und Brüssel
hin und her es gibt Rückfragen und ähm
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob wir da heute
noch eine Entscheidung sehen aber wir
wissen ja alle die Zeit drängt
was mir jetzt noch aufgefallen ist ist
dass Volker Wissing ja auch damit
argumentiert mit mit so einer
preisargumentation also sagt das ist
auch seine Aufgabe dass ich jeder Bürger
und jede Bürgerin in Deutschland
zukünftig noch mobil bewegen kann jetzt
ist ja aber eigentlich der aktuelle
Stand dass diese e-fuels relativ teuer
sind und gerade ja auch diese
Technologie für die Masse noch nicht
wirklich denkbar ist oder ja absolut
also ich habe mich da wirklich mit sehr
vielen
Experten über diese e-views unterhalten
ich bin auch mal nach Karlsruhe Gefahren
zu diesem Institut die da federführend
forschen an diesen an diesen
synthetischen Kraftstoffen und habe
damit den Experten gesprochen und im
Grunde sind auch die sich einig äh das
dass sie sagen das ist eine Technologie
die wir brauchen werden für Schiffe für
Flugzeuge also für all die Fahrzeuge die
schlecht Batterie elektrisch betrieben
werden können ja aus ganz praktischen
Erwägungen und für die werden wir
irgendwann wenn wenn wir wenn wir
technisch soweit sind werden wir diese
diese Reviews brauchen für den großen
PKW Massenmarkt für die bestandsflotte
ist es eher unwahrscheinlich dass dass
das zum Einsatz kommen kann da gab es
jetzt auch noch mal eine aktuelle Studie
gerade in dieser Woche die sagt die
werden niemals ausreichend zur Verfügung
stehen in ausreichender Menge die haben
ein paar Probleme also a sind sie teuer
in der Herstellung und B sind sie auch
in ihrer in ihrer Energieeffizienz also
das was an Energie am Rad irgendwann
ankommt liegt nur bei 15 bis 20 % sagen
Experten ich bin keine Physikerin aber
nach allem was ich verstanden habe lässt
sich das auch nicht ändern also an über
diese 15 bis 20% Energieeffizienz wird
man wohl mit ifus nie hinauskommen egal
wie sehr man daran forscht das ist
einfach Physik so habe ich es mir
erklären lassen ähm daran wird sich also
nichts ändern aber Volker deswegen
argumentiert das haben wir gerade gehört
auch in seinem Statement über den Preis
er sagt eben ihm würden die Experten
wiederum sagen dass der Preis sich
irgendwann anpassen könnte an die an die
an die Preise für Benzin und Diesel und
dass der Markt das regelt das ist ja
eine sehr fdp-typische Position dass man
eben sagt wir hoffen einfach dass oder
wir wollen dass es am Ende einfach der
Markt entscheidet
ja Stichwort technologieoffenheit das
ist ja ein Begriff den die FDP häufig
nutzt oder jetzt seit neuestem
Technologie Neutralität lass uns noch
mal in einem Stück auf diese e-fuels
gucken vielleicht ist dann einigen von
euch das auch so ein bisschen klarer
efuels sind synthetisch hergestellte
Kraftstoffe im Idealfall soll dieser
Ersatz Sprit ganz ohne Rohöl hergestellt
werden zunächst wird aus Wasser
Wasserstoff gewonnen dafür benötigt der
Strom soll grün sein also das Windkraft
oder Sonnenenergie kommen
gleichzeitig wird CO2 aus der Atmosphäre
herausgefiltert über einen
Zwischenprodukt Methanol kann dann
neuartiges Benzin Diesel auch für
Schiffe und sogar Kerosin für Flugzeuge
hergestellt werden die CO2-Bilanz ginge
dabei auf denn es wird nur so viel CO2
ausgestoßen wie zuvor der Atmosphäre
entnommen wurde allerdings Abgase wie
Stickstoffoxide würden beim fahren
weiter entstehen wie bei jedem
Verbrenner und bei der Herstellung
entstehen beim Energieaufwand viele
Verluste die Folge die Energieeffizienz
bei der Produktion und beim Fahren mit
Ephes ist noch viel zu gering ein E-Auto
kann mit der gleichen investierten
Energiemenge bis zu fünfmal so weit
kommen
ein normaler Benziner noch doppelt so
weit das zeigt sich auch bei den Kosten
heute kostet ein Liter efeel 4,50€
aufwärts im Jahr 2030 könnten es unter
der Voraussetzung einer
energieeffizienten Massenproduktion
zwischen ein und zwei Euro sein efuels
können für schwerere Fahrzeuge wie bei
der Feuerwehr LKW Schiff oder Flieger
einer Alternative sein in der
Elektroantrieb an seine Grenzen stößt
Ephes für alte oder etwa neue PKWs
erscheint nach derzeitigen Stand
unrealistisch
ja und ich habe hier gerade mal einen
Blick in eure Kommentare geworfen unter
euch scheint es sehr viele zu geben die
da was den Streit angeht eher auf
wissing-seite sind hier fragt zum
Beispiel Philipp Lederer auf Youtube ich
verstehe halt den Punkt nicht wieso
etwas verboten werden soll das angeblich
sowieso keine Zukunft hat Cristiano
kannst du uns das beantworten
nein das das kann ich natürlich auch so
nicht beantworten aber klar ist das sagt
ja Volker Wissing auch immer ihm ging es
nicht um diese an sich geht es ihm nicht
um die Kraftstoffe sagt er immer ne mir
geht's nicht um die es mir geht's um den
Motor also was er will ist dass der
verbrenner motor an sich erhalten
bleiben kann das hat ja auch in
Deutschland ganz viel mit mit Industrie
zu tun er mit Arbeitsplätzen zu tun ich
glaube es sind 800.000 Jobs die in
Deutschland in etwa an der
Automobilindustrie hängen und das war
eben bisher vor allem der Verbrenner und
er will eben dass dieser dieser Motor
weiter Bestand hat und dass wir eben am
Ende in der Lage sein werden da nicht
mehr Benzin oder Diesel rein zu gießen
sondern eben für uns reinzugeben aber
das eben die Antriebsformen an sich
nicht ändert darum geht es ihm und
deswegen twittert er auch heute morgen
solche Sachen wie das ist das Aus für
den Verbrenner aus weil er eben will für
das Verbrenner aus entschuldigung das
Aus für das Verbrenner aus weil er eben
nicht will dass das Verbrenner aus an
sich beschlossen wird sondern dass man
diese motorform erhält nur was man da
eben am Ende reingeht das hätte er gerne
offen lassen
ja wir halten jetzt mal fest nach diesem
statten gibt es noch nicht so richtig
viele News wenn es aber News gibt
Christiane dann sprechen wir uns wir
zwei uns bestimmt noch mal vielen Dank
erstmal bis hierhin dass du unsere
Fragen beantwortet hast
wir machen das Bild mal so ein bisschen
auf thissing drückt sich weiter unklar
aus gleichzeitig ist ja in Brüssel
gerade oder Tag der EU-Gipfel und da
scheint der Druck auf eine Einigung in
diesem Streit ziemlich hoch zu sein ich
habe hier mal einen Ton von der
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
für euch
time ist auf jeden Fall drängt denn
dieses Gesetz ist eine wichtige Säule
unseres klimaschutzpaketes fit for
fifty-five
ja und darüber wie Brüssel jetzt auf
diesen Streit und vielleicht schon auch
auf dieses Statement von Volker Wissing
gerade guck darüber spreche ich mit
meiner Kollegin im Busse Isabell
Schäfers hallo Isabell hallo
ja erzähl uns doch mal wie guckt Brüssel
aktuell auf das Verhalten unseres
Verkehrsministers was ist da so die
Stimmung zu also ganz offiziell sind die
Töne hier eher positiv und ein bisschen
runterkochend also gestern Abend hat man
ja gerade gehört hat die
kommissionspräsidentin noch mal gesagt
wir sind auf einem guten Weg aber sie
hat eben auch noch mal appelliert und
betont dass die Zeit drängt und der
Bundeskanzler hat sich jetzt hier gerade
ganz aktuell vor einigen Minuten
geäußert und gesagt man werde schon eine
Einigung finden
gestern konnte man aber auch feststellen
hier bei den Staats- und Regierungschefs
auch heute morgen dass da schon eine
gewisse Art von Unmut da ist viele
wundern sich doch was da in Deutschland
gefahren ist das ganze jetzt noch mal
aufzumachen das ganze könnte eben auch
Schule machen dass man eben einen
Kompromiss der eigentlich lange
geschlossen ist dann noch mal auf
verhandelt das will natürlich eigentlich
hier niemand und dass das ausgerechnet
Deutschland ist die das jetzt machen das
hat hier schon auch ein bisschen für
Überraschung gesorgt jetzt haben sich ja
auch schon einige andere Länder wie
Italien und Österreich Deutschland da
angeschlossen
wir wollen jetzt auch noch mal mehr rein
verhandeln also das sorgt hier schon
einfach für Unmut auch wenn das beim
EU-Gipfel eigentlich offiziell kein
Thema ist hinter den Kulissen merkt man
in der EU-Kommission dass da schon auch
ja ein gewisser Unmut da ist gestern
Abend kam dann auch ja relativ böse Töne
aus der Kommission die über
Medienberichte verteilt wurden dass der
Bundeskanzler hier davon sprach dass die
Kommission ja bereits eine Zusage
gemacht hätte das sei so nicht richtig
also hier ist schon auch ein gewisses
gegeneinander zu fühlen und wir hören
hier das gleiche was auch Christiane
sagte dass da einfach noch sehr viel
Bewegung drin ist da werden Papiere hin
und her geschickt niemand weiß mehr so
richtig wieder eigentlich der aktuelle
Stand ist die EU-Kommission hat uns z.B
heute auch jeder Art von Statement
abgesagt weil sie zum Beispiel sagen wir
warten eigentlich jetzt auf eine
Reaktion von Berlin wir warten auf eine
formelle ein formellen Brief aus Berlin
und ähm eine Einigung ist hier eindeutig
noch nicht in Sicht das ist das was die
EU-Kommission jetzt hier sagt
okay es scheint also so als sein heute
alle sowohl Wissing als auch die
Kommission weiter in Arbeitsprozessen
ich würde gerne noch mal auf einen Punkt
eingehen die du gerade angesprochen hast
und den auch her wissen gerade
angesprochen hat er sagt ja es er hat
mittlerweile die Unterstützung von
anderen EU-Ländern das wirkte jetzt
lange nicht so es wirkte immer wie so
ein riesen Streit Deutschland gegen den
Rest du sprichst nach gerade auch davon
dass ich andere Länder mittlerweile
anschließen oder wie ist das ja das ist
so ein bisschen offen was eigentlich wer
will also man muss da glaube ich ein
bisschen zwei Dinge trennen einmal sind
das andere Länder die auch andere andere
einfach andere Dinge fordern die jetzt
gar nicht unbedingt diese ifuels angehen
es geht einfach darum dass man sagt auch
wenn Deutschland jetzt hier noch was
rein verhandeln will dann können wir
vielleicht noch was anderes rein
verhandeln und dann ist ja auch einfach
die Frage die Christiane auch eben schon
aufgeworfen hat was will Volker deswegen
eigentlich weil wenn man sich jetzt mal
anguckt was er auch eben in seinem
Statement gesagt hat was jetzt ein
Kompromissvorschlag sein soll nämlich
das Auto Verbrenner Autos ab 20 35
weiter ifuels tanken können wenn
sichergestellt ist dass sie keine
anderen herkömmlichen
Treibstoffe tanken können das ist ja
genau der Vorschlag den die
EU-Kommission bereits vorgelegt hat den
Berlin aber abgelehnt hat das heißt es
geht hier weiter eigentlich gar nicht um
diese inhaltliche um diese technische
Umsetzung sondern vor allem um die
rechtliche Grundlage da war ursprünglich
mal ein Delegierter Rechtsakt im
Gespräch das klingt sperrig das ist ein
Zusatz den die EU-Kommission machen
könnte dieser Zusatz könnte aber vom
Europaparlament gekippt werden und der
ist Europaparlament hat für das
Verbrenner ausgestimmt deswegen war
Volker Wissing bisher gegen diesen
Kompromissvorschlag der EU-Kommission
obwohl er inhaltlich eigentlich genau
das gleiche gewollt hätte und was jetzt
genau diese Rechtsgrundlage sein soll
das blieb ja eben bei dem Statement von
Wissingen auch weiter offen das heißt
man weiß ja eigentlich gar nicht so ganz
genau was da jetzt kommen soll und
deswegen kann man auch nicht sagen dass
es wirklich andere Länder gibt die sich
jetzt hundertprozentig dieser Forderung
von Deutschland angeschlossen hätten es
geht eher ganz generell um das Gefühl
dass auch andere Länder jetzt ein
bisschen auf die Idee kommen bereits
getroffene Kompromisse womöglich noch
mal aufzuschnüren
ich habe gerade mal so einen kleinen
Blick in unsere Kommentare geworfen und
um zu schauen was die Community da
draußen also was euch so beschäftigt die
sagen einige auch ähnlich wie Volker
Wissing wir müssen offen bleiben für
alle Technologien es sagt aber auch
jemand elektromobilität ist die Zukunft
ifuels nicht nicht weiter so das ist das
was unser Land braucht fahren so im
weiter so ist nicht zielführend und
jetzt setzt ja die EU aktuell auch eher
auf Elektromobilität kannst du schon
sagen warum die EU so auf
Elektromobilität setzt
naja ich glaube gegen elektromobilität
ist ja niemand so richtig also das ist
eben ein Standbein der der
klimaneutralen verkehrsmobilität der
Zukunft und das ist eben das worauf sich
auch bisher viele einigen konnten das
Elektromobilität natürlich eine große
Rolle spielen wird und die e-fuels das
hat Christian ja eben auch erklärt und
das war ja auch in dem in dem
erklärstück sehr schön zu sehen sind ja
einfach noch nicht so weit dass man
sagen könnte dass sie dann auch ab 2035
tatsächlich diese große Rolle spielen
können deswegen sind natürlich ist
natürlich die E-Mobilität an dieser
Stelle erstmal naheliegender
wir haben gehört du hast heute kein
Statement bekommen von der EU-Kommission
wir haben einen Scholz der sich geäußert
hat wir haben einen habe der sich heute
morgen geäußert hat jetzt haben wir ein
bisschen der sich weiterhin erstmal
unklar geäußert hat was schätzt ihr denn
so in Brüssel wann gibt's denn da neue
Ergebnisse also wann kommt man denn
vielleicht mal aus diesen
Arbeitsprozessen raus und kann wirklich
noch mal erzählen worum es jetzt
inhaltlich geht oder was der inhaltlich
der aktuelle Stand ist ja wenn ich das
wüsste ich glaube das wollen wir sehr
viele gerne wissen also aus der
EU-Kommission kam eben eher die
Vermutung dass es sich heute nicht lösen
wird und auch sonst haben wir das gehört
dass man eher nicht davon ausgeht
kommenden Dienstag treffen sich hier die
EU Energieminister die erstmal nicht ähm
fachlich etwas mit dem Thema zu tun
haben aber die könnten theoretisch wenn
vorher eine Lösung gefunden wurde diese
neue Einigung dann verabschieden im
Moment geht aber niemand davon aus dass
es tatsächlich bis dahin eine Lösung
gibt die dann von den energieministern
formell verabschiedet werden könnte aber
nach dem ganzen hin und her in den
letzten Tagen kann sich da wohl niemand
so ganz sicher sein
hier fragt noch mal jemand noch mal zum
Thema warum unterstützt die EU einige
Dinge andere will sie verbieten Heiko
Wernsdorf fragt auf Youtube gibt es
einen bestimmten Grund dafür dass ich
die EU so rigide gegen
Verbrennungsmotoren für PKWs stellt das
hängt ja wahrscheinlich mit den
Klimazielen der EU zusammen oder ja ganz
genau und da muss man vielleicht auch
noch mal differenzieren was ist
eigentlich die EU weil es jetzt auch
immer wieder gesagt wird die
EU-Kommission gegen die FDP oder gegen
Volker Wissing aber dieser dieses
Verbrenner aus was beschlossen wurde das
hat ja nicht einfach die EU-Kommission
entschieden sondern das ganze basiert
auf einem Vorschlag der EU-Kommission
der dann in einem monatelangen sehr sehr
ausführlichen sogenannten
trilog-verfahren zwischen allen
Institutionen also zwischen dem
Europaparlament wo ja gewählte
Abgeordnete drin sitzen und allen
Mitgliedstaaten verhandelt wurde das
heißt alle Mitgliedstaaten auch
Deutschland auch die FDP hatten da
bereits ein Wort mit zu reden und haben
sich darauf bereits geeinigt in einem
monatelang Verfahren das ist ja ein eine
Verfahren wo wirklich alle
die nötige Zeit und immer wieder
Gelegenheit haben auch etwas anzumerken
also man sollte das nicht so stehen
lassen dass sie die Kommission etwas
vorschlägt und jetzt die FDP dagegen ist
sondern dazwischen stand schon sehr sehr
viele andere Schritte
ja gut dass du das noch mal ansprichst
wie diese Zusammenarbeit eigentlich
funktioniert was sagt uns dieser Streit
denn jetzt den ja alle ganz verwundert
angucken erst hatte man sich dafür
entschieden jetzt stellt man sich
dagegen was hat der denn vielleicht auch
für ja zukunftsauswirkungen was heißt
denn so ein Streit den wir jetzt haben
vielleicht für die zukünftige
Zusammenarbeit mit der EU
also ich glaube alle hoffen ja einfach
dass das jetzt nicht Schule macht es gab
gestern eben bereits erste Äußerungen
auch sorgenvoller Äußerungen z.B auch
von der
europaparlamentspräsidentin Mezzola das
eben keine Verlässlichkeit mehr
eigentlich in dem Gesetzgebungsverfahren
so wie wir das kennen besteht wenn das
jetzt Schule machen würde die Hoffnung
ist einfach dass das jetzt ein
Einzelfall bleibt aber man hat ja schon
ein gewisses Unverständnis auch dass das
hier so eine Koalitionskrise hier in
Brüssel für so viel aufheben sorgt eben
wie ich eben beschrieben habe das ist ja
ein sehr sehr langes
Gesetzgebungsverfahren wo alle eben ihr
Mitsprache recht haben und deswegen
besteht ja einfach ja die Hoffnung dass
das jetzt keine Schule macht wenn es
Schule machen würde dann würde die
gesamte Europa Gesetzgebung einfach sehr
unverlässlich und zuverlässig und noch
wesentlich komplizierter und noch viel
langwieriger werden
Isabel danke dir für die ersten
Eindrücke aus Brüssel ich denke wird
zwar werden uns auch noch mal sprechen
wenn es da weitere Erkenntnisse gibt
danke dir
ja das Thema scheint auch euch ziemlich
zu bewegen ich sehe in den Kommentaren
wird ganz viel über E-Autos diskutiert
da gibt es eben die Menschen die sagen
E-Mobilität ist die Mobilität der
Zukunft es gibt aber auch viele Sorgen
unter euch hier schreibt Karl auf
Youtube ob das eine gute Idee mit dem
Verbrenner aus ist hat mal jemand an die
Landbevölkerung gedacht und auch jemand
anders auf Youtube schreibt gute
Technologie setzt sich von selbst durch
staatliche Bevormundung in Form von
Verboten und Subventionen ist völlig
überflüssig ja wie sich dieser Streit
zwischen Wissing und der EU
weiterentwickelt wir bleiben auf jeden
Fall für euch dran schön dass ihr dabei
wart